[Music]
foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half an hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with political
correspondent at the financial times
Jasmine Cameron cheleschi and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boating there they are standing by but
first let's see what's on some of those
front pages the gloves are off that's
how the Metro describes the latest
exchanges between former presenters
Phillip Schofield and Eamonn Holmes over
the behind the scenes culture at top ITV
show this morning
Boris Johnson's WhatsApp account and
what it might reveal to the covid-19
inquiries top story for the Times which
says a legal Wrangle is looming over
getting the messages released
the mail leads with what it calls Fury
at labor leader sakir starmer over a one
and a half million pound donation to the
party from a top funder of the just stop
oil movement and demands it should be
returned
the mirror speaks to the mother of a
ten-year-old boy killed by a dangerous
dog who is backing the paper's campaign
for government action to stop more such
cases
the eye reveals that people could be
asked to recycle less waste to cut down
on the number of non-recyclable items
finding their way into the recycling
system and having to be rejected
the express says that High Street banks
are under increasing pressure to offer
better rates to Savers after a witch
report found rates at the moment are
often meager and unjustifiable
the financial times leads with news that
labor is planning to Force Major
landowners to sell off plots cheaply if
it gets into power in an effort to cut
the cost of building new homes
and that is also the top story on the
front of tomorrow's Guardian
while the star tells us that experts
think we've been drinking our beer the
wrong way and that it needs to have more
of a head on it because it's better for
your Bell
there you go and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see ons
you'll see on screen during this program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
let's speak now to the political
correspondence at the financial times
Jasmine Cameron cheleschi and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boating who are here with us to review
the papers this evening great to have
you both with us thanks so much
um Anita I'll kick off uh with you first
if I may because we're going to be
talking about the front page of the
Metro their headline leading on this
ongoing storm at ITV the headline the
gloves are off what's this article's
thing
yes so this updates
um the world on the latest Ferrari
between
um presenters and former presenters now
of ITV so this is um Phillip Schofield
opting on his Instagram page to
effectively
um dismiss the claims of toxicity behind
the scenes at itb's this morning
um to which the former presenter Eamonn
Holmes who left the program in 2021
according to the paper has then
responded on Twitter saying you don't
want to pick a fight with me pip
um it's all quite public now the The Rao
um between the former presenters and
obviously the
um bad feeling ever since um Philip slow
Scofield was it appears to um be was
sacked as a result of what has been
reported to be
um conduct with OR carry on with an
employee who was there at quite a young
age so
um it's definitely something that has
kept I'm itb's this morning in the front
pages over the past few days and this is
a sign that it perhaps might not be
abating anytime soon yeah certainly the
storm rumbles on and and the future of
the show in doubt uh very much so now
Jasmine to you Nexus let's talk about
the front page of the Guardian because
uh just so the viewers are aware you've
asked not to comment tonight on uh this
morning given that you are moving to ITV
later this summer so let's talk about
the front page of the Guardian labor to
let councils buy land cheaply to tackle
the housing crisis this story on two of
the front pages today
yeah so it's a really interesting story
and it looks at the fact that labor
officials are discussing plans to give
local authorities powers to buy up land
cheaply and then develop it and of
course we know that housing is set to be
one of the key issues going into the
next general election be that what's
happening in the rental market or what's
happening with mortgages or trying to
get more first-time buyers on the ladder
so it's a very interesting set of
proposals that the party are discussing
and of course labor officials know that
actually if they put forward a strong
electoral offer particularly to those
aged between 21 and 40. those
individuals who typically would be
getting on the housing ladder would be
starting families and would
traditionally be voting um becoming more
conservative with age but statistics
show that that's not happening and so
labor officials feel like if they can
tap into that core voter base actually
they've got a strong offer to put to the
public and it will be quite interesting
to see how cchq how the leveling up
Department engage with these brief
proposals and perhaps they'll try to
offer some sort of counter alternative
going closest the election
yeah and Anita is there anything you'd
like to add to this kissed armor is is
under Fire for his promise to make it
easier to build on the Green Belt as
well
yeah and he's got this sort of broader
ambition to have 70 of people
um in the UK to be homeowners and it's
it's very clear that labor doesn't
really have a clear idea about how
they're going to achieve this so um it's
interesting that we've got this
announcement now about compulsory
purchase orders and I won't bore your
viewers by trying to explain exactly how
this works effectively um local councils
can acquire land in quite limited
circumstances and there's an indication
here from this story that they're going
to allow local councils to go much
further than that but I don't see here a
clear indication of how this would make
a demonstrable difference
um to the broader housing ecosystem in
particular around house building
um because often councils acquire
property basically for development
purposes and not for necessarily
straight for building houses so again I
think it's a lot of ideas sort of
slightly throwing things at the wall and
seeing what things would make a
difference because actually increasing
house buildings that substantially is
quite a significant Challenge and I
think it's interesting that labor thinks
this is winning ground and it's
certainly cleared the public want to see
more house building but achieving that
it's actually quite complicated it's not
clear that there is a comprehensive plan
for delivering that
okay and just on uh political and policy
ideas Jasmine this story inside uh
tomorrow's Metro about uh Rishi sunak's
plans to perhaps put put a price cap on
on the cost of essential Goods to help
with the cost of living crisis uh it
certainly sounds according to this
article that there are some industry
figures who who doubt whether it will
work
yeah so these ideas were briefed to the
weekend papers I think they first
emerged in the Sunday Telegraph this
idea that ministers were discussing
perhaps a voluntary cap on essential
items now we all know anyone that's gone
to a supermarket we've seen the price of
basic as like milk eggs bread cheese
Dairy all of this has gone up and it
really is impacting particularly lower
income families and so the government
has briefed out these proposals but
there really has been a bit of a
backlash on all sides that you've had
conservative MPS and ministers who were
very instinctively against what they
feel is excessive State Intervention
basically arguing that this isn't really
conservative proposal and then you have
um leading business figures arguing that
actually this isn't really going to make
much of a difference and it just feels a
little bit like posturing so it seems as
though the government is scrambling to
look as though it's got some effective
proposals to bring down inflation now if
we remember bringing down inflation is
one of cenac's five pledges to the
public that he wants to halve and play
Asian by the end of the year so
obviously there's a little bit of a Mad
scramble at the top of government as to
as to how they go around doing that you
know how they create a perception that
actually the government is on top of
this issue and is doing all it can and
exhausting all channels to really look
as though it's on the side of the voters
on the side of consumers to get some of
those prices down yeah it's interesting
isn't it uh this idea uh Anita what do
you make of this you know mad scramble
at the top of the government as Jasmine
put it there what do you think is going
on as a former conservative advisor
I wouldn't quite call it a mad scramble
but I do think that the figures out um
earlier in the week about inflation and
particularly about the levels of core
inflation that we're now seeing in our
economy is deeply worrying and I think a
sincere concern in number 10 and
likewise in HMT about the level of
inflation that now seems to be
um slightly bedding its way in and what
that means for people because inflation
does you know sort of destroy the
economy for a lot of people in terms of
how how much poorer it can make people
and the government doesn't have a huge
number of levers that it can use and to
support that and we know that the
supermarkets are very much you know
wanting to do their best for consumers
so I think it makes sense to me that the
government would want to talk to those
retailers and say look what more can we
do to make sure that across core areas
and it's particularly um when it's
purchasing items that people who are
poorer will see and feel that
inflationary hit much higher what can we
do to keep those prices is down at a
point where food inflation is at a
30-year High
um so I think it makes sense for the
government to be having those
conversations it doesn't look like the
government is looking at regulating and
it's much more about a voluntary
agreement but if it does come up in some
fashion I think that would really help
some of the poorest people who are
really struggling with food prices yeah
it's interesting isn't it let's talk
about the front page of tomorrow's mail
Jasmine before we go to a short break uh
Fury at storm is one and a half million
pounds from just stop oil donor their
headline uh tomorrow morning saying that
kirstama is under Fire over donations to
labor from a key funder to just stop oil
yeah and I do think we will probably see
more and more of these stories heading
into the general election as there's a
lot more scrutiny over where parties are
getting their money from who's donating
what the stories behind these figures
and of course um just stop oil is the
Environmental Group that has been
embroiled in some level of controversy
in the past few months over some of the
tactics that it's used to to get its
messaging across and so in that light
particularly there are individuals who
are arguing that stormers shouldn't have
accepted the money or now should return
the money as some sort of gesture I'd be
skeptical as to whether that would
actually take place but I think as I say
there'll be more and more of these
stories and more of a bit of a rifling
through you know the party's expenses
and and figuring out who's funding some
of these political parties and how much
we can read into that
yeah Anita your your thoughts on this
story certainly just stop oil
um has divided opinion in the way
they've they've carried out some of
their protests
really um is we've seen the announcement
um recently from kirst armor about
stopping a naughty oil drink and
Drilling and that's obviously about
whether the UK can remain energy secure
so there's clear indication here I think
that
um just stop oil or whether it's via
this connection from the donor or
whatever is is impacting the labor party
policy and that's where I think there
are some genuine concerns because the UK
isn't a yes at a stage where it can only
use renewable energy for instance and
therefore you're in a situation where
either you know the UK is producing its
own oil and gas or the UK is buying it
on the global market and we've seen
what's happened to Global oil and gas um
prices recently so I think there is a a
broad and more serious concern about the
energy Security in the future if
geostormers policy comes to fruition but
I think an interesting as yeah yeah
sorry I don't know why I Had a Brain
fade in your name there
um I think that as we get closer to the
election there'll be more scrutiny about
the motivations behind some of these big
policies that will be coming from both
political parties